whether there will be or won't be
football this year i continue to be in
there
will be football camp
you got to get ready
if you are a football player to play
football even if the national football
league players association has said
don't have team workouts until training
camp tom brady still having team
workouts that aren't exhibiting a whole
lot of the things that you would expect
in a pandemic and they can't be
employing the protocols that will be
adopted by the nfl and the nflpa because
they haven't been adopted and
communicated to the teams in detail yet
i see this
as flaunting
the workouts and giving a middle finger
to the nflpa
he's open about it he's bragging about
it he's using it for social media
credibility the fdr quote the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself i and
that is so reckless i i and look i
understand he's tom brady i understand
big cat he's the greatest quarterback of
all time
but that's all the more reason for him
to not be doing this stuff he's been the
most talked about player the entire
offseason
and at a time when all the numbers are
going up in most states in some states
alarmingly
you can't be peddling this the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself no
we have to fear a virus that has killed
122 000 plus people and counting and you
need to have it's it i'm not saying hide
under the bed but but but don't don't go
out there and do things that your union
is saying don't do
and then wear it like some weird badge
of honor that is what i'm having a hard
time processing can you help me
so all right so the quote i agree with
you there that seems like it's flaunting
it that seems like it's kind of you know
sticking a middle finger to uh the
pandemic in the virus the fact that tom
brady's out there practicing is the
least surprising news ever because if
there's any kind of wiggle room that
he's gonna take here if there's any uh
ability to have a loophole an
interpretation of the rules to allow him
to get an edge he's going to take it
that's why he's tom brady and i i kind
of have no problem with it because he
either got to be it's kind of a
microcosm for the entire pandemic mic
the
the ability to to to let the public know
exactly what's going on
to to be clear from you know government
state government federal government
whatever it may be on exactly what the
guidelines are have been all over the
place since day one and they've had
trouble relaying messages they've been
late on messages they've masked things
back you know back and forth so while
i'm still wearing a mask and i'm still
following all the protocols you have to
also understand there's going to be
people who aren't because there is that
wiggle room there that they've been able
that they've been allowed by some uh
really bad leadership
yeah i mean and and the wiggle room is
going away in some states and people are
losing their minds over it because
instead of making everyone stay home now
at this point in the life of the
pandemic
people are being required to wear masks
by governmental entities and
and and there just continues to be this
strange
political component
where
there's a segment of the population that
refuses to wear a mask and that will
come up with all sorts of
justifications that range from
disingenuous to bizarre for not wearing
a mask out in public whether to protect
themselves to protect others to protect
family members because they may be
asymptomatic carriers who catch it
somewhere while not wearing a mask and
it never affects them but then they give
it to grandma or grandpa and then
grandma grandpa die i mean it's all very
simple logic and you've got
trained medical experts telling us what
we should and shouldn't be doing and
then you've got people out there who are
in a position to influence others who
are engaging in behavior that is
antithetical to the behavior they need
to be engaging in and that's where i put
the onus on tom brady he needs to
realize that he is tom brady he needs to
realize he's not the 199th overall draft
pick in this year's selection process
even though he still has that chip on
his shoulder he's got 7.7 million
followers on instagram people pay
attention to him and i understand he's
trying to build his brand but at the
same time he's doing damage because
there's two groups that he's affecting
the people who
are convinced they should be concerned
that that kind of comment from him
yesterday may cause him to say maybe i
shouldn't be concerned maybe the only
thing to fear is fear itself and then
the people who are determined to not be
concerned this is the kind of thing they
can seize on to justify their position
yeah the only thing to fear is fear
itself yeah that and the virus that can
kill people and that is killing people
and is sickening people and even if it
doesn't kill you there's more and more
evidence that it can have lasting
effects on your lung and other parts of
your body and what i can't figure out
big cap
i mean i've got the tb12 book signed by
tom brady
not even humble brag i mean but it's
nice nice nice book and a nice little
message in there and all this stuff
about recipes and avocado ice cream and
all the things you do to treat your body
like a temple
how does that mindset
all of a sudden stop
when there's a virus
that can mess up this temple that he is
that he is trying to keep finely tuned
and honed with avocado ice cream i can't
i can't bring those two ends together
oh i can absolutely rectify those two
things because think about it tom brady
uh has been successful he tom brady is
one of those guys and it you see it in
every single industry where the success
a lot of times you try to figure out
okay why was i so successful why what
gave me this success probably the answer
is tom brady's really really good at
football and works really really hard
but he's also found other parts you know
the the longevity of his career there's
got to be answers for it so he's found
the answer the tb12 method so there's a
belief in i don't want to call it
pseudoscience but clearly there's uh a
a
search there for what exactly has made
tom brady tom brady and why he's been
able to play for so long so i think that
curiosity of well
something that's maybe outside the box
of traditional science that's why i am
able to do what i'm able to do and
that's probably also the same strain
that's finding this virus and saying i
gotta go out there and i gotta practice
and i'm trying to win at all costs and i
don't really care
look i mike at the end of the day
uh i just i think that the message has
been bungled and it should have been i
think i said this two months ago that it
should have been from day one to to
actually get to the american public wear
a mask or else we're not gonna have
football season they should have been
having psas where people are sitting
down on the couch and it's like you can
see the trees the the leaves falling off
the trees and they turn on the tv and
there's it's a blank screen and then it
says
what is it you know could you imagine
october without football wear a mask
like they actually should have made that
a message and a selling point because
that would get through to people you
know people don't like to be told what
to do and uh i think you need to tell
them that if they don't follow at least
some guidelines we might not have sports
and i keep watching all the soccer
that's going on in europe right now and
i get frustrated that we don't have
anything going on in america it's so so
frustrating to watch that happen and
we're going to get to liverpool and
their championship yesterday but i i
just can't i can't believe that people
can watch sports happening around the
globe and being like why don't we have
these back yet
and that has been your message for the
past two months to make it very simple
and plain and understandable for the
sports fan and yes there are
altruistic reasons for wanting the
pandemic to go away for wanting the
virus to not spread you don't want
people to get sick you don't want people
to die but from a sports band's
perspective to the extent you're living
in your own little bubble and you feel
impervious to the outside world and you
don't think you're gonna get the virus
the bottom line is if the virus can keep
football season from happening that's
reason enough
to take the virus seriously because it
may take away your ability to enjoy
football season former college coach
bill curry played in the nfl years ago
he tweeted this yesterday if americans
had really wanted to watch football this
fall we would have paid attention to
masks suggestions and social distancing
from the beginning it's not complicated
and that's what you're saying and that's
separate apart from the more important
aspects of it but even
for the people who truly aren't
concerned it is going to take away
something potentially that you care
about very deeply and that's part of the
irony of what tom brady is doing by
sending these messages does he not
realize that that attitude he's
projecting will contribute to the
possibility that all this stuff he's
doing at the high school field in tampa
is a waste of his time because there may
not be football because of it
yeah
i think what what people have failed to
learn
overall and in the last three months is
that by nature we're kind of all selfish
and in order to get something done in
order to have everyone tug at the same
rope at the same time in such a massive
scale you have to play into the people's
selfish reasonings and unfortunately
saying hey your neighbor or your
grandmother or whatever it may be may
die from this
it's sad to say but it really has not
hit home in some parts of the country so
guess what will football football not
being there would absolutely hit home
because everyone wants to watch football
in the fall and if you don't have that
people are going to be very upset again
and we're going to have no one to blame
but ourselves because again i go back to
watching soccer every single day and i
am watching live sports and i love live
sports and i'm wondering why we can't
have it you know here stateside
yeah and in a weird sort of way and i'm
going to try to psychoanalyze tom brady
here and a lot of professional athletes
i feel like especially for brady now
that he's still playing professional
football into his 40s i feel like that
he has managed to extend for 20-plus
years that weird sort of
invincibility that you feel when you're
18 19 20 years old you're you know
you're you're young and you're fit and
you you know you yeah yeah i'm gonna die
maybe i won't die maybe i'll be the one
who never dies you know like like you
feel invincible you feel immortal you
feel like you nothing can touch you and
and maybe if you can defy the odds and
climb to the highest level the nfl and
still play with all these guys much
younger than you you are expanding that
that window as long as you can and i'll
tell you what i remember when that
bubble popped for me that bubble pop for
me 37 years ago monday when joe delaney
drowned because i had just graduated
high school a few weeks before that and
i was in that kind of like yeah this is
good man you know i'm going to do this
i'm going to be just like this for the
next 100 years and and you know i'm a
huge football fan at the time and i know
who joe delaney is very well and he
drowns trying to save three kids in
louisiana and that is whoa that that's
the thing that snaps you out of that and
i feel like when you have a high level
of a success in professional sports and
it continues and continues and continues
you just feel like you're you're that
doesn't affect me i'm above all that
that doesn't apply to me that applies to
all the other people out there who are
going to age and who are going to die it
doesn't apply to me the nfl's version of
dorian gray does that make any sense at
all
it absolutely makes sense i think that
they're you know until you're probably
25 i mean you have a little bit more of
a memorable moment mine probably was
when i had you know the first two-day
hangover of my life but
when you're in your early 20s
you feel invincible and when you're an
athlete at the highest level and all
these guys are in insane shape and
they're in you know i know that it's
weird to to have to like couch this but
they're alphas through and through and
they absolutely are at the tip top of
every you know spectrum when it comes to
the physical abilities they would of
course they feel like they're invincible
why wouldn't you feel like you're
invincible if you have that type of
power and athletic ability and so yeah
that absolutely makes sense mike and i
do think it goes back to the tb12 method
where he has
uh you know life hacked a way to play
football for so long and be so
exceptional at it
there's he probably thinks he can light
hack away out of this too
and and there every once in a while
there's this kind of weird whiff of
of almost kind of a voodoo mindset that
he can cure concussions and recover from
concussions and concussions aren't a
problem remember a few years ago his
wife blurted out he's had a bunch of
concussions and he has concussions and
and and he never he never disputed it
there's just been this weird sense that
he thinks he's got the way to crack the
coat on that and and and maybe he's
walking around with the virus thinking
uh if it happens i'll figure out a way
to crack the coat on that as well i've
got an extra suit of armor because of
all the avocado ice cream i've eaten
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports